many who have endured the covid-19
pandemic understand this nuisance
this time seals and Peru are being
tested for bird flu or h5n1 which is
spreading through the region and taking
with it hundreds of sea lions
it initially started with Pelicans last
year now it's affecting these marine
mammals
we have recorded since mid-January the
unusual deaths of many sea lions so far
we have about 716 dead in seven
protected areas
crew recorded its first cases of the
highly infectious virus in November and
since then the government says it's
killed 63 000 Birds
but globally since 2021 the world
Organization for Animal Health says more
than 200 million birds have been killed
or culled to contain the virus it's
seeing the worst ever outbreak
Health experts say outbreaks usually
begin in Autumn and fade by Spring but
reports are becoming more frequent they
blame Rising cases on global
temperatures forcing Birds to alter
migration patterns changes in farming
methods and increase movement between
countries of animals and humans
to keep it contained they say
surveillance and isolation are important
but more needs to be done to build up
vaccine stocks
and although the risks to humans is low
it remains a public health
concerns
we know this bird flu virus is highly
pathogenic on birds but it can also
infect mammals if I'm not wrong there
was a case in Ecuador where a child got
infected and now sea lions are getting
infected it's likely more people will
more cases are popping up across South
America for now in Peru sea lions are
being carefully buried to contain the
spread
Laura Khan Al Jazeera